A school
shooting in Serbia's
capital, Belgrade, has left
eight children
and the security guard dead.
Serbian officials
say the alleged shooter is a 14 year
old student.
He's now in custody,
according to the Interior Ministry.
Another seven people are hospitalized.
Stop the plane.
Following all these developments for us.
What happened is not sort of
sorry we hear from Serbia very often.
It's certainly not
and especially not from this school,
which is in an upscale part of Belgrade,
one of the most famous schools
in the city.
But we know that this happened around
eight 40 in the morning
according to the authorities.
Police,
there was
obviously a massive police response
when this 14 year old boy
walked into this school with two pistols,
a nine millimeter
and a smaller gauge pistol,
and started shooting.
Police also said
that he had four Molotov cocktails
with him.
When police got to him,
he was actually in the school yard.
So what we know about injuries
right now
is that there were nine
killed, eight of them
kids, one a security guard.
There are seven people
injured, six of them
children, one of them
a teacher,
a 53 year old, we understand,
suffering from gunshot wounds
to her stomach and her hands as well.
There is also one girl
that at last word was undergoing
life threatening surgery
inside of the hospital.
As I said, this is a 14 year old boy.
So seventh grade,
there was a picture of him
coming out of the school there.
They only identified him
thus far by his initials, k. K.
He had a jacket over his head.
Skinny jeans on.
He got into an unmarked police car
and was taken away
Shortly after that,
we also saw students or at some point
we saw students also coming out.
Some of them were quite visibly
distraught
as they were coming out of the school.
One girl was in tears.
A mother told our local affiliate
there that
her daughter is frankly in shock.
She cannot get her to calm down
right now.
There's a press
conference happening right now
with with authorities
from government and from police.
And police
have described
this as something
that was being planned
for more than a month now.
They said that the shooter had a plan
as to which specific classrooms to go to.
Apparently, the history one was chosen
because it was near to the door
which specific students to go after.
And so this seems like
something is preplanned
One official blamed
the influence of Internet
video games
so far as sort of an initial cause.
The gun came from where
and how common a guns that. Yeah.
So initially
the initial report
at least,
is that these are guns
that were taken
by this 14 year
old student from his father.
So guns
are not nearly as common in Serbia
as they are
in, say, the United States,
which is why you don't
hear this kind of thing from Serbia.
It's also a very small country,
but there are also strict gun laws.
You in order to get one,
you can only get a semiautomatic.
Automatic guns are banned,
but in order to get one,
you basically have to go through
a medical exam.
You have to go through a background
check.
You have to have a reason
to have one likes
for hunting or a good reason
to feel like you're under threat.
And you also have to do
a training course.
There's also lots of guns though.
Left were left around
from the Civil War back in the nineties.
And so one estimate from 2018
suggested that Serbia actually
per 100 people
had the third
highest rates of civilian guns
floating around there.
The number is 39 per 100 people.
But just for comparison's
sake,
the US number is 120 guns per 100 people.
So obviously not nearly as common,
but one of the more commonplace
is to find guns,
certainly in Europe and the world
Okay, Scott, thank you.